我把这几盘走了
都给它串出来
等一下让明明也过
把这角落里的都给它串出来
我的老腰
我把这角落里的都给它串出来
累死我了
啊
断 断网
刚断了一下网是不是啊
我这里卡了
我刚刚看了一下我这里卡掉了
不知道有没有
反正都在这了
角落里都已经全部扒拉出来了
不辛苦希望能找到
我大概
大概看了一下
没看到
买了
领导
来这个远领
来这个腰身
后面有隐形拉链呢
后面有隐形拉链的
来这个上衣
春秋天穿
得
等老板娘来了
我问他
看他有没有拿走
来这一款
brothers
揣 gaining
如果找不到的话
啊
来我来量一下
来胸围胸围
胸围96 98 96 98
腰围86 88 86 88
来长度前面65后面73
来这个谁要29扣个2
29谁要谁来扣个2
谁要谁来扣个2
扣个2扣个2
来这个咖色的这个圈
前面有一排扣
它的牌子是这个牌
牌子是这个牌子
这个牌子的啊
来来来有裤有裤眼
有裤有裤眼
这一款我看一下什么码
单层没有里层
人棉92
聚脂8
人棉92啊
聚脂8%
来这一款咱们来量一下
你听一下
看一下两边有鞋扎口袋
两边有鞋扎口袋
腰后面带松紧的
来这一款咱们来量一下
你听一下
胸围
胸围96 100
来腰围68
可以拉伸了86
68 86
来裙长裙长
113 114
来这个裙子谁要谁来扣
39 39扣个3
来这个裙子非常好看
谁要谁来扣
39 39
39扣个3
来这一下
新款嘛
你来啦
这个我都没看到过
它是棉98
棉92聚脂8%的
你要不要再看看
这个款我都没看到过
我在等你呢
我又过了半裙了
过到半身裙了
这个牌
我想着等你来再过
这个牌子
两边有口袋
单层
棉92
棉92聚脂8%
面料超好
两边有鞋拉口袋
看腰后面带松紧的
单层
这个穿的是要绝对舒服
39 39
划算的很啊
苹果气泡亲爱的
39你要不要来一件
看看非常好
它是有一排扣
走这里到下面全是有扣有不远的
两边有口袋
棉92哦
没有瑕疵
我给你检查
没问题
给你吧
,
来
收到货让你惊讶
看有没有瑕疵说的那么好
先放一边想想
OK
好吧
你想着明天来帮我帮我
明天来找我买
我先挂后面
妈呀这是个啥东东
睡裙呀
没见过的都是新款对
我这个是睡裙吗
FLC他们家的
FLC4L
面料锯纸
面料锯纸的滑滑的
腰是松紧腰底边带花边袖口有够有够呀
4个L
4个L 4个L的啊面料锯纸
来胸围胸围108 112
腰围90 102
90可以拉扯到102
来长度长度120
长度是120
来这一款谁要谁来扣29 29扣0扣0
来喜欢的姐姐就扣
家居裙嘛
这个像锻料一样的滑的很
29 29
来
扎我就要
扎不
扎不了
来这个全棉全棉底边带
刺绣的
棉100棉100
的这个加
这个这个我又说家居裙了
这个是一个民族风的全棉两边有口袋
两边有口袋底边带刺绣的
底边带刺绣领口有个盘扣
领口有一个盘扣
来这款全棉全棉
胸围胸围胸围
胸围112 116
112可以拉扯到116
来群长群长群长
来
119群长119
来这个原来也是59的29
29扣个2
我跟你说苹果七包像刚刚那个棉92的最少都这里要卖59
真的呀
都给你们便宜了宝贝
真的瑕瑕不骗你
都给你们便宜了
来谁要谁来扣29扣个2
谁要谁来扣个2
我一本正经的跟你说
一本正经的给你说
有这个裙子你看你喜欢吗
这个藏青色的
直筒裙
后面有隐形拉链
后面有隐形拉链的
看这个裙
这个9块
来腰围是74 76
腿围102 106
102 106
长度58
长度58 9块9块扣0
9块
大了大了是不是
9块扣0
太大了
上面写的44的
上面写的44
能穿
就是夏天的
就是夏天穿的宝贝就是夏天穿的
看看
就是夏天穿的
这个来这一款来给我们看素干的
有两个颜色
好的
来396
321好谢谢
应该是我买过的
这个吗
那个
那个吗
那我不知道来亲爱的
你在我手上是没有买过
来这个翻脸素干素干的蓝色
来来这个衬衫
溜宝溜宝的后背交
后背是打褶的啊
来这款咱们来量一下面料句子
来
胸围胸围
102 104
来
长度
前面70
前面70后面75
来这款谁要9块9块扣0
9块9块
谁要谁来扣个0
9块扣0
来这一款来给我们看一下3L的
面料是
人民20巨值80
领口带珍珠的
领口带珍珠装饰的
来这一款咱们来量一下
胸围胸围
胸围120 126
120 126
长度61
来9块9块扣9
9块扣9 9块扣9
9块扣9
谁要谁来扣
哇这个这个是贵货
香王说的这个挺贵的
直筒的
这个裙子好像吊牌架老贵了
这个没有标了之前有过到一个白色有标上面写的是个6
上面写的是个6
来这一款
直筒裙直筒裙后面有隐形拉链
来包裙包裙的哎呦这个有瑕疵
有瑕疵
这个抽丝了看
这个往这边